[Music]
[Applause]
uh jonathan fagan who uh covers the
rockets the beat writer for the houston
chronicle joining us and uh
jonathan any drama any updates here
well i don't know if james harden's been
able to get his leak past working so he
can watch the preseason game tonight
that might be drama other than that i
think
uh today's been quiet so far all right
update us on where things stand what it
what is fact and what is fiction
here with uh the rockets and harden
yeah i mean the overriding fact is he he
wants
to be to a team he can consider a
contender
which he considered the rockets to be in
past years and apparently
no longer feels that this team is a
championship contender
that part hovers over everything uh he
he showed up on tuesday began his covid
protocol testing should be able to
practice when the team gets back from
chicago
on monday assuming everything goes well
with the testing
and the rockets have to decide what they
want to do
is slow play this as much as possible
take their time get determine when
if they are to deal him they can get the
best deal
now trade deadline or next summer
factoring in that if you can determine
yeah i get a better deal later
you also have a chance however small or
to whatever degree the chance is
that he'll decide hey this team's good i
want to be here i
i don't know how great a chance that is
but if you trade him there is no chance
of that
so there's advantages for them to wait
what do you make of the report yesterday
that uh you can add the miami heat
milwaukee bucks
to that list with the nets and the 76ers
who
who's adding that hardness adding that
yes but you know he had previously told
them contenders
so putting names by the word contenders
doesn't really change much we can all
determine
who the contenders are and if we were
we would probably start with the best
record in the league last year and the
team that went to the finals in the
eastern conference last year
so that doesn't really move the ball
when it comes to the decisions the
rockets have to make
the rockets if they are to trade him
they can trade him anywhere they want
and to me if you're a bad team if you're
a team
stuck in that never get in the playoffs
or
barely fight to be a first-round loser
team
hey load it all up go for them now most
of those teams don't have anything to
load up
or not enough but the rockets are not in
any way compelled to move him to a
contender
they just got to move to whatever team
gets the most
back which is a future star
they want his successor as the next star
and they want a hall of draft picks
why aren't the knicks in on this
jonathan like the knicks usually do
something stupid and
why not have somebody that people show
up to watch
well there's a chance the knicks are no
longer the stupid knicks that
they finally have escaped that and
but do they have the guy who's going to
be that next star
do any of their young up and come or rj
barrett or something to the rocket say
oh boy
you know we're going to rebuild around
that guy that's where they fall short
and so it's a and that's where we can
both go back and forth well what about
this
what about cleveland what about
minnesota
you start looking at teams and you can
make the money work
but who's got a next
best player in other words teams aren't
trading their best player
whose next best player fits the rockets
criteria
of a successor to james hart and i'm
trying to understand this so jonathan
and you're there on the front lines but
it feels like james harden has been
running this organization for a while
or at least deciding who's coming and
who's going
uh if it's a coach who's going to be
going and another coach comes in
i think he might have wanted ty lue
instead of silas but
james harden was trying to build himself
a championship team it didn't work
and now he wants out and i gotta blame
him for
some of the things that have happened
here like he doesn't take ownership in
this to say
you know what it didn't work let's try
another way uh
a new philosophy yeah it's good to be
the king
yeah uh it's absolutely i mean the most
obvious example is he
really wanted to reunite with russell
westbrook
uh they they remained friends and they
do still by the way
uh they are still friends and they never
really had issues but
they weren't a good fit from the idea
and obviously to now he wanted that
and the rockets to use their term went
all in for that
i mean two lightly protected first round
picks chris paul
and two potential pick swaps they traded
much of their future now they thought it
was good too
at the time chris paul had an
injury-filled year they thought
there was a chance that would be the
future for him
so it's not like he dragged them kicking
and screaming and they didn't want it
but they did it to appease him that's
not it at all
but he wanted it wanted it badly and he
made that
very clear to daryl mori who went all
out to go all in i mean that's the most
obvious example but yeah he's made a lot
of decisions or had a lot of influence
and he's been kept in the loop on all
kinds of things
for years because they thought daryl
especially believed that creates a
partnership
well the partnership doesn't seem to be
going very well right now because
he he it's sort of like hey we had a
great year
eight years of marriage but you know i
found somebody better
well you know the one you want to leave
isn't too thrilled with that
what happens next here i think the most
likely thing is he shows up and
practices monday
and they carry this on into the season
in the hopes that
they'll be good enough that he and he is
very
prideful player he's a very driven
player they're not
concerned he's going to pout his way
through the season or anything like that
the rockets don't believe that'll be the
case it's a huge setback though with a
new coach and a lot of new players
it's a huge setback losing a week of
practices with him
in this kind of season but that's what
is the most likely
if they're not a good team if they're a
fringe
playoff team do they have to make a move
at the trade deadline or do they do it
next summer
one thing to keep in mind raphael stone
the new general manager
is very capable of saying no
james i want to be traded do it now no
yeah but i want to go to brooklyn no
rafael can
is he can do that and he would do that
uh that whatever decision they make is
going to affect this franchise for five
to seven years
so a half a season when there's hardly
any fans in the building anyway
they can put up with that and do
whatever they think is best whatever
that costs
who's in better shape the rockets or the
texans
well you know the texans have
the superstar right they have desean
watson so
my my inclination is to say them
the rockets have the asset
and it is basketball where
you know one great asset brings one
great player you're suddenly
a factor you know i'll say the rockets
the rockets have a general manager
you know they have a coach they have a
general manager
both teams have stars right now
although it's probably more unpleasant
right now and difficult
they really like the coach they picked
they're very happy with that choice
the rock the texans don't know who their
coach is going to be so
rocket jonathan should be fun we
appreciate your time thank you have a
good weekend
all right thanks you too happy holidays
that's a jonathan fagan he uh covers the
rockets for the houston chronicle